την εκόμενη μέα σε έναταλεύκωσε τ το δύσκολον περιβλλουαυτό θασε ένα δύσκολο περιβάλλω στο υπουργείο
γεοργίας συνήθως ήταν άντρες το διμόνιτου υπουργείο γεοργίας ημιώθετι το οργανωμένα σύνολα αποσχετίζονται με τα
υπουργειο γειοργιας σας υποδέχθηκα θετικά τότι α τα γυναίκα έπεξεν το ρόλον του να ξυπρ
καταρχει ι μεγάλη τιμή το ότι είναι η πρώτη γυναίκα υπουργός στο συγκεκριμένων υπουργείω σύπου
ίνα οι αντιλήψεις του κάθε ανθρώπου διαφέρουν δεν μπορώ να πω ότιτα τα οργανωμένα συνα
γνολά δηλαδή το αγρωτικό κίνημα με υποδέχθηκε διαφορετικά ι υπήρχει και υπάρχει πάν έν ένάς
αμιπαίος σεβασμός αυτό το οποίο ίέπραξα και μου του το έχουν πι πολύ γειοργείμετα από
μόνη τους ήταν το ότι δεν περίμεναν ότι θα μπορούσανανταποκριθώς τις προσδοκίες τους και ήρθαν
ήδι έτσε γίδιμε μιαν ενόχι συνήδηση να πού δεν το περιμένομε να λλό τελικά τελευταίως
ατω ς γεργού ότι ισον η πρώτι που κατέβηκες που το αυτοκίνητω και πάτησες με
στο χωράφι ναιλ α κο κύριος διοικητής να θεωρότιμε ι πρώτι προφανός του έχουν κάμειζο
άλλή συνααδελφοι από μένα πριν απόμένων και θα τογάμουν τ άλι κείνον το οποίο όμως
έχως βασικήμο αρχή και τού το θεωρώ εγκάτι που αντικατοξηρίζει όλα τα μέλη της της
κυβέρνησης τω ικού χρστοδουλίδι είναι ότι είμαστε δίπλα πόυ τους συμπολίτες μοδίπλαβους συμπατριώτες μας και
μαζίν τους δεν επικοινωνήσουμε α δεν μιλήσουμε δεν συναναστεραφούμε με τους ύνδους τους ανθρώπους πεφαρμόζουν
τις πολιτικές μας οι πολιτικές μας δεν θα ανταποκρίνονται στις ανάγκές τους παρα ένα παραίτητο
τ υπήρξε στιγμή που μάρια επετι κανοδαμε ναφίοδεν προλαβαίνεις να σκέφτησης τοτ